it's official fans are loving the new
Star Wars show Ahsoka and they're taking
to social media and droves to share
their thoughts minor spoilers for the
first two episodes ahead after the
Standalone series starring Rosario
Dawson premiered on Disney Plus on
August 22nd 2023. fans hopped on social
media to discuss just how happy they
were with the show which takes place a
few years after the events of the
Beloved animated series Star Wars Rebels
led by Star Wars Guru Dave filoni the
series also Stars Natasha Loop ordizzo
Mary Elizabeth Winstead Ivana sakno and
the late Ray Stevenson in one of his
final roles so what the fans really
think of the latest Star Wars project
after seen Dawson bring the character
into the live-action realm and the
Mandalorian they're thrilled her solo
Adventure is off to such a strong start
one fan posted on Twitter the first two
episodes of Ahsoka just deliver on every
front everything that made Rebels so
special is beautifully translated into
live action and the Heart and Soul of
this incredible story remains strong
bologna has done it once again General
sandula
see you another fan agreed posting first
episode of Ahsoka is breathtakingly
beautiful and I'm in tears with how well
done they brought the animation to real
life a sweet and fitting tribute to Ray
Stevenson and an amazing Cliffhanger
another fan kept it simple with their
reaction posting last night's Premiere
was epic meanwhile this fan got much
more specific writing I think one thing
I really loved about the first two
episodes of Ahsoka is that the show
really isn't afraid to take its time
each scene and moment feels
appropriately drawn out and we get to
sit with the characters for longer than
any moments in Mando ever allowed
you're going to want to hear what she
has to say Dawson already Charmed
audiences in the Mandalorian and as a
result she's built up a lot of Goodwill
as a character which this fan made clear
I just watched the first two episodes of
Ahsoka and holy how good Rosario Dawson
is leaning into this role the best piece
of media so far this year another fan
made it clear that even if you're not a
Star Wars expert there's something for
everyone on the show I honestly think
the first two episodes of Ahsoka do a
great job introducing all the main story
beats and characters to prep anyone to
be able to understand and enjoy it even
if you haven't seen Rebels or Clone Wars
there's even something for Star Wars
fans who have serious franchise fatigue
according to this fan who posted I
actually like it a lot so far and I've
been super critical of Disney Canon for
the most part translating a beloved
animated show into live action could
have been a tough feat but clearly
felony and his cast met this challenge
head on as one excited fan wrote the
first two episodes of Ahsoka were so
freaking good like in my opinion this is
already some of the best Star Wars
content poetic Cinema Star Wars Rebels
solidarity man I cannot wait for more
episodes to come another fan agreed
saying I didn't want Ahsoka episode 2 to
end this felt like live action Rebels
especially with the music Chopper baby
the casting is perfect so being ran
being ahsoka's Apprentice is epic
this haircut
it's more me some fans just felt elated
seeing their favorite characters make
the leap from animation to live action I
can't explain the serotonin rush I get
watching Ahsoka and seeing Hera Sabine
and lothal and live action so impressed
with how good it is so far the cider
writer Megan O'Keefe posted that fans
are the latest major Star Wars project
Andor might take issue with Ahsoka but
she liked it all the same initial Ahsoka
thoughts Dave filoni lovingly brings his
Rebels to life in a story that Embraces
mythology magic and lore in a way that
could turn off say Andor fans slower
Pace than expected but still enthralling
for this Rebels fan Natasha Lou bordizzo
is my early MVP other fans were relieved
that Ahsoka who wasn't wildly popular at
first is finally getting her due like
this fan who posted well it took 15
years but I've finally seen the
introduction of Ahsoka Tano who went
from a character of Star Wars fans
initially hated to one of the most
beloved characters in the franchise the
bottom line is this fans really really
like Ahsoka even die hard Star Wars fans
are on board YouTuber Star Wars Theory
who's definitely an expert in the field
gave the series his seal of approval
posting just watch thehsoka again to
complete my breakdown of episodes one
and two and I like it even more the
second time around the first two
episodes of Ahsoka are streaming on
Disney plus now and new episodes drop on
the service every Tuesday
foreign